i ragazzi a ginseng e tir che è un gioco
fatto dalla soft pop chiedere che capì
che ne sono però belga lamis il game
oddio proprio inconscio va in giro a
cure
vado a trovarti una cura ok fa anch'io
ma chi è a casa un premio sd per
muoverti ok io sono tutto storto a chi è
lei che devo trovare la cura per lei non
andiamo a trovare una cura ma va a mano
troviamo cure come se non ci fosse un
domani living dr a tema o non so neanche
cosa devo fare in stagione devo trovare
una cura ma non ho capito non c'è una
spiegazione non c'è niente fa e devo
trovare una cura ma in che senso c'è una
farmacia in giro trova una farmacia tifo
qua c'è un fiore vede un fiore lo prendo
più fame rais flowers l'energia massima
aumentata di 2 l'energia massima che
cosa devo fare il suo gioco spiegatemi
qualcosa fino adesso non ho capito nulla
di quello che ho fatto e nel perché ho
speso questi tre incredibili euro però
qualcuno vi darà una risposta lo spero
wanted alla madonna ricercati
viaggiatore ciao mi chiamo salvatore
finisci modalità
ok prendo l'arma è un abito tiger wood
di rana zanzara tigre
no una cimice tira che sono dei beatles
scarafaggio tech my money york va bene
piccolo non mi ricordo solo dire dello
scarafaggio tigre dico mai trovato
un'arma usa il mouse per attaccare
bloccare ok ma cos'è apostolo sports
night va bene non ho capito che c e b la
cimice tigre proprio bastarda secondo me
la cvc uno scarafaggio awards dove ti
batto io sono forte e premi cooper focus
ari nemici sigma ed dark souls perfetto
bello l'effetto sonoro della spada vedo
che questi 31 sono ben investiti ok
demi jet che possono cambiare le armi
ragazzi giochi crisi un nuovo dark souls
va bene serve lei non è scontroso e non
è uno stronzo
salve tornerei indietro se fossi te una
rana è stata avvistata più avanti in
questa strada quindi io rimango qua no a
devo farla fuori zio devo farne fuori
tre sono tre boss
ho pagato questo gioco per farli fuori
tutti quindi devono mi dispiace vado
addio gente volante maori a di alcuni
sono dei buoni bloccatori premi f per
scalcia per calciarli e stanarli gay
il problema non è quella prima che
madonna che botta il problema è che non
aia e che mi giro dall'altra parte di un
hotel che combatto aiuto ce la fai a
morire no ragazzi sono morto io non sono
riuscito a ucciderlo
sei stato ucciso sei minuti e 22 secondi
ma cosa vuol dire susa web un tu chi
scegli un'arma da mantenere
questa l'ultima bambù play come ho speso
i miei soldi
ho bisogno di un consulente finanziario
soc.pop ho bisogno di un consulente
finanziario che mi e mimì minimi
consigli come spendere meglio i soldi
perché fortemente non lo faccio proprio
bene suri devo chiedere assurdi come
spendere i miei soldi in modo più equo
vi fanno scattare quando salta avranno
un senso ho visto pure impegnando cieli
piccoli le botte muoiono allora avevo
già fatto sto discorso siamo già stati
quasi dieci come siano dalla partita che
almeno germoglio già applicato non mi
deve calciare il gioco portava che non
devo morire ci sono sia alcuni sono più
forti gli altri incroci siamo paolo
picchia lo hyatt picchiano uccidilo
madonna è veramente fortissimo a
bloccare questo perfetto bravissimo come
stimato anna sono un fenomeno sono
cacchio più danno più velocità ma meno
durabilità forte sega questa c'è la john
hlavin dr va bene c'è il molo ma non c
era sto tizio prima a come 5 battola nei
progetti fortissima questa che faccio
c'è qualcuno qui dietro ma non c'è un
pezzo di nitra attenzione fighissimo ma
che sono diventato questo è un gioco
questo è il nuovo dark souls è veramente
difficile da padroneggiare ma io ragazzi
cioè ciao proprio ora quello come è
morto stecchito
ci siamo famiglie dove la rana le faccio
un buco del culo che non avete idea
salve da che parte sarà solo un occhio
maledetto eccolo allora ho sentito molto
parlare di te parco lemonia né fatto
malissimo ei picchia una donna madonna
va beh ma è fortissimo cpa con la lingua
questo vorrei che lo facesse una ragazza
non tu ma non vale
ma non vale fortissimo ma è fortissimo
vi piglia una lingua informali ma come
faccio
ma non posso sono morto quattro video 50
su due auto meno le prima sceglie l'arma
da mantenere ma lei tanto non mi cresce
al gioco era perfetto porca vacca
ragazze ti prego non mi crescere semi
che lasci non vale a è il momento va
avanti ormai ragazzi rocket è diventata
risposta tutto se non trovo se non trova
niente gioco a rocket vi spiego questa
dinamica qua io perché molti vi faranno
perché fa vj giochi sempre ai giochi
brutti miei mi spiego ragazzi questa
cosa è molto molto semplice io in
qualità di tua bj non sono un gameplay
air gip giochi tipo call of duty e ora
manager si può capitare che riporti ma
in realtà giochi che vedete sono quelli
brutti
i marroni prima serata non sono giochi
brutti e semplicemente la terminologia
che usano le persone che non conosco i
videogiochi questi sono giochi ovvero si
è messo un cristiano a farli
se messo un cristiano a farli treni
cavoli suoi
in sé per sé il gioco è anche carino
tipo colori prima però molto spesso
capita che sono pieni di problemi tipo
questo che mi ha lasciato ma voi non
sapete quanti gameplay
nella mia vita ho buttato perché il
gioco
a un certo punto smetteva proprio di
funzionare cioè non avrà il creato del
gioco non aveva fatto il continuo porco
del demonio come un segnato scusate il
caso che mi sono messo lì con la
pazienza di tutto il mondo a dire vabbè
mi mette a giocare di giochi sul mio
canale come format dei giochi indie
chiamano così non siano giochi brutti
siano jokin di che sono fatti da qualche
cristiano strano ma perché gli faccio
perché sono giochi totalmente anni
spectec c'è tutto quello che succede è
talmente strano che non lo puoi trovare
in giochi normali che completing
software cioè veramente raro trovare un
gioco che tipo golf simulator un gioco
della madonna seggi pensato anche se hai
fatto appositamente da cani
anzi la capra e ti permette di scherzare
in modi non potresti scherzare con
giochi che compre agli in stoffa per
farti capire infatti capi la come sta
grandi linee tutto tutta sta facendo a
questo perché questa situazione mi porta
a provare giochi tipo colori prima
che non voglio buttare perché officina
finestra che peraltro poco a tori dovuto
buttarlo ma ne approfitto per spiegarvi
questa cosa anche perché sono pigro non
ci voglia di farlo e quindi è visto che
ogni tanto mi capita di buttare
debuttare non buttare il gameplay ma
magari gli devo unire insieme perché un
gioco solo non basta rapito oggi non
c'avevo il gioco per allungare il
gameplay quindi mi metto a farlo perché
purtroppo sono a casa mia a torino e la
connessione non mi permette di scaricare
teoria così velocemente riesco in
qualche modo a sfruttare l'occasione per
spiegarmi questa cosa diventa molti mi
definiscono soprattutto i giornalisti
bon gamer ma c'è una particolarità in
tutto questo io sono molto più gamer
nella mia vita privata vuol dire che io
nei cup quando faccio i cacchi miei
gioco a videogiochi che non porto sul
canale ad esempio cosi world on va
l'orante tutte queste ore perché perché
se riportarsi su youtube non si
sposerebbero per bene con il mio format
nel senso che non riuscirei a a
diventare comico su call of duty perché
che cosa posso dire dibattuto su quello
che dio dio mio dio colom ha ucciso il
gamer vista dal giornalisti e power
ok io invece sono più un intrattenitore
che utilizza i videogiochi come mezzo di
comunicazione per la comicità è come
mezzo di trasporto cioè sono un tramite
i videogiochi per me per fare comicità
però in realtà io sono molto più
intrattenitore che gamer ecco questo
volevo dire questo per questo significa
che anche molte persone che mi seguono
magari di videogiochi non ne sanno una
marcia e mi seguono perché magari
gli piace loro la loro piacente stile di
commentare di comicità in generale ecco
questi temi questo vuol dire invece è
difficile che qualcuno segua power se
magari non conosce i videogiochi ecco
quindi ragazzi questo era un parlare per
arrivare a dieci minuti modo tale da
monetizzare video grazie avermi
ascoltato ci rivediamo in un prossimo
episodio di vi parlo di cazzate per
arrivare a 10 minuti in cerata fatemi
sapesse disparte scherzi questioni sulla
sua stanza esser fatemi sapere cosa ne
pensate voi se avevate già capito questa
cosa se non ve ne frega una sega di no
serio aspetto se non ve ne frega una
sega dei videogiochi navi seguite perché
vi piace il modo in cui commento se vi
piace videogiochi che porto che è un po
difficile alle volte però sono molto
curioso di sapere in percentuale quanti
voi mi seguono per un motivo o per
l'altro e quanti voi vi seguirebbero lo
stesso senza fare videogiochi molto
interessante questo argomento
specialmente perché quando gioca come un
giochi come quali prima un po mi passa
la voglia poteva la mia non è vero che
ci vediamo al prossimo video ragazzi
scrive di schiacciate tasto mi piace
lasciatemi un commento qua sotto perché
mi interessa sapere la vostra veramente
non sto scherzando
come sempre ci vediamo ad un prossimo
video bella ragazza
[Musica]